5 56 on your friday morning what's
driving to crazy how about a viewer
question about a ramp
where the 95 meets the 215 northern
beltway
let's go centennial
bowling
all right viewer patrick wright so glad
the centennial project's almost
completed however
and dot seems to have forgotten about
the ramp from westbound 215 to the north
95 is endot going to address this in the
near future
well patrick the answer is yes but the
only specific timing
is that that part of the project is
going to start early next year
now a recent centennial bowling report
focused on how oso blocker that sort of
frontage road just western 95 how that's
going to be replaced
well that same end dot graphic shows all
of the work that's going to be part of
what they call
phase 3d that does include building a
ramp that will take
westbound drivers to the northbound 95.
now this final phase of the centennial
bowl also involves
other connections there's going to be a
ramp from the east 215 to
the north 95 and here's a really cool
one there's going to be a connector ramp
from oso blanca west of the 95
over the 95 to sky point ndot's
centennial bowl website has
all of this info and a lot more we've
got a link to nevada us95nw.com on our
website 8newsnow.com you just click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8 news now dot com